the protagonist is an ambitious girl
named chi she is a beautiful singing
voice and her dream is to star in a
musical drama someday but behind the
happy face she hides a dark secret that
defies all laws of nature she has the
unique power to see how much time a
person has left to live it is more of a
curse for her because she can do nothing
about the deaths other than wait for the
inevitable one afternoon she is
traveling by bus when she witnesses a
series of crashes on a bridge the police
and paramedics arrive immediately and
begin rescuing people she looks at the
chaos from a different perspective than
everyone else because she can see how
much time the people have left then she
comes across an older couple who are
shaken by the accident but not hurt as
she hands the wife a band-aid she
notices the husband has only a minute to
live she stands there helplessly unsure
what she should do eventually the man
suffers a heart attack she tells the
wife to calm down and enjoy the last
minutes with him she is glad to have
helped even a little bit because her
power makes her feel helpless in
situations like this after that it is
revealed that she has only 167 days left
knowing that she will die in a few
months she wants to live her life to the
fullest this is why she auditions for
every musical show in the town hoping to
land a role sometime later she visits a
woman named miss o in the hospital
despite the age difference they are good
friends miss o has been dating a man
named mr park since yesterday she
notices that he only has 67 days to live
while miss o still has two years she
doesn't react to the info but feels bad
for them then she is just leaving the
hospital when she is hit by a car the
car happens to be driven by a young man
named lee who suffers from anxiety
attacks and is afraid to drive he is the
son of a wealthy businessman and the
owner of a budding entertainment company
she isn't hurt but instead of
apologizing lee blames her for being
careless they get into an argument
before he forcefully makes her sit in a
wheelchair he wants a doctor to check
her so she won't take advantage of the
situation and sue his ass later this
causes her to run extremely late to an
audition she asks lee for a ride and
gets inside the car even though he
repeatedly asks her to go away upon
noticing that he is afraid to drive she
gets behind the wheel and reaches the
destination in a blink after she wishes
him goodbye lee realizes she has taken
the car keys with her he follows her and
ends up in an auditorium then we are
introduced to a strict musical
choreographer named joe he is a
perfectionist and rejects even the best
of the performances she is nervous but
she sings a beautiful song about
childhood love lee watches her from the
audience amazed by her talent but joe
says her performance lacks meaning he
asks her to prove that she has been in
love before she panics and scans the
audience upon seeing lee she rushes to
him and plants a brief kiss on his lips
still joe remains unimpressed and she is
rejected lee on the other hand is
shocked he accuses her of stealing his
key and assaulting him she simply hands
him the key and apologizes before
leaving seeing her cry makes lee feel
bad for yelling at her at night she
meets her best friend sung he who knows
about her gift as they talk we find out
that no matter what she does to save a
person from dying it never works even in
the safest condition they either die
from a heart attack or an accident
somewhere else lee is on a romantic date
with his girlfriend b she is also the
daughter of a wealthy businessman and a
perfect match for lee but unlike him she
is arrogant and manipulative lee has
proposed to her several times and she
accepts the rings every time but never
says yes she knows that lee is not in
love with her and wants him to feel the
same way she does before marrying him
lee is going to china the next day to
meet an investor the next morning chi
also gets an offer for a scuba guide gig
in china she says goodbye to her mother
and younger brother before catching the
flight after landing both lee and chi
end up staying at the same villa lee's
secretary informs him that the investor
zhen has planned for them to go scuba
diving the next day although nervous lee
can't say no to an investor later the
group goes scuba diving and lee finds
out that she is their guide they dive
into the water under her leadership and
explore the ocean after the tour she
leads everyone back up when everyone is
on the boat she realizes lee didn't
follow them she quickly dives back in
and finds him lee who had given up hope
is relieved to see her they share the
oxygen tube and swim upwards while
holding hands just then she notices that
her timer has frozen she looks at it in
shock and falls unconscious when she
wakes up she is inside the boat and the
watch is working normally but when lee
comes into the room it stops again a
shocked chi stares at him and then back
at her wrist to test if lee stopped it
she walks away from him as she had
predicted the timer only stops when she
is near him this would mean that if she
stays with him she might have a chance
to live longer in the following scene
she is back in korea with sung he she is
just as shocked when told about the
timer stopping on its own moreover she
remembers that she didn't see a timer on
lee a week later she is informed that
lee and director joe are teaming up to
organize a musical it is a large level
project with a high budget if she gets
the part she will be closer to lee and
at the same time will fulfill her dream
starting the next day she trains like
crazy and prepares her best for the
performance meanwhile lee and joe
silently fight to get more authority
over the selection process joe doesn't
want anyone else's interference in the
play but since lee is the organizer he
pushes his way in on the day of the
audition chi performs a song and does
way better than the last time strangely
enough the song makes lee feel a weird
sensation in his heart almost as if his
heart is beating to the rhythm unable to
bear the feeling he comes outside chi
notices his absence and tells seung-hee
about it being a good friend she thinks
of a plan to set her up with lee the
results of the audition will be
announced later but she had made it her
mission to stalk lee and lengthen her
lifetime this is the first good excuse
for stalking i've seen on this channel
later she goes to his office and poses
as a candidate applying to be his driver
lee asks her to get out but she insists
that she is the best person for the job
when lee leaves she even follows him to
his home and boldly asks him out on a
date he denies the proposal but before
they can talk further a group of three
men interrupts them they are actors sent
by seung-hee to attack lee the plan was
that she will save him and win his heart
but they all end up in the police
station the police officer calms lee
down and asks him to stay in the waiting
room while waiting chi dozes off on his
shoulder lee wants to hate her for it
but he cannot help but feel a warm
sensation in his chest he touches her
hand and rationalizes it as him paying
her back for saving his life while scuba
diving what they both do not see is that
the timer in her arm goes into reverse
lengthening her life instead of
shortening it after that he and chi come
outside initially she tries to talk to
him and he ignores her but before
leaving he gives her the car keys and
asks her to be on time tomorrow she has
actually landed the job as his driver
which means she can be with him often
and lengthen her lifetime while driving
away lee watches her celebrate and
smiles the next morning he finds out all
the background information about her chi
was born into a wealthy family but after
her father was imprisoned for money
embezzlement they had to face a huge
loss the family's current living
conditions are not ideal but she is
ambitious about her future then lee goes
outside and watches her singing happily
while waiting for him he doesn't know it
but just looking at her makes him feel
better about everything they drive to
his office and the entire time he tries
hard not to look at her throughout the
day she doesn't leave his mind making
him go crazy at one point he starts
yelling at his laptop imagining that he
is chi that's what i do when i'm in love
with a girl too i yell at her she on the
other hand tries to stay as close to him
as possible later that day they bump
into joe who remembers chi from the
audition he complements her voice and
says that she has improved from the last
time the results are yet to be announced
but the comment makes chi very happy lee
notices the change in her mood and feels
a pang of jealousy when she gushes about
the director the jealousy turns into
irritation and he asks her to shut up
what an alpha later lee sees a picture
in his office that he doesn't like
anymore his assistant takes it off the
wall and comments that he doesn't like a
picture for more than three months lee
registers that if he looks at one thing
for a long time he no longer finds them
attractive he decides to use the same
technique to get rid of his feelings for
chi hence after work he asks her to come
with him for dinner she is confused
about the sudden kindness but she agrees
to go unlike what lee has thought he
cannot stop staring at her and gets even
more frustrated for a while she is alone
and gets a call from her father in
prison lee sees how much she misses him
and feels bad for her after dinner when
they are walking to the car lee happens
to hold her arm she notices the timer
going in reverse and is shocked she
doesn't tell lee about it but the
concept is wild for her since she had
accepted her death a long time ago then
lee brings her to the cinema saying that
he has to get his mind off of things she
as a good employee follows him behind
while they are watching the movie she
wants to make sure that the timer
actually stops when she touches him she
unknowingly touches his hand which gives
rise to an awkward interaction lee gets
so close to her that she feels her
cheeks fluster she looks back at the
timer and as predicted it has reversed
the following day she gets an email
saying that she hasn't been selected for
the musical she bumps into joe in the
hallways who says that her voice had
emotions but she wasn't able to express
them she is a raw gem but they are
looking for a polished one for this
musical when he starts criticizing her
she snaps back she calls him a peanut
and walks away leaving both him and the
audience baffled later that day lee and
bee run into chi and b finds out that
she is the new driver she instantly gets
her guard up and invites her to dinner
with her and lee he doesn't want to go
with both of them but she doesn't seem
to have a problem with it at the
restaurant they are informed that only
two in-house seats are reserved so chi
will have to stay on the terrace and eat
alone lee asks her to return home
because it would seem like they are
disrespecting her but b argues otherwise
she even hands chi a check to pay for
her meal in the end lee and bee are
eating together but he cannot stop
looking at she she is enjoying her meal
which is surprising to lee because to
him she was just humiliated bee excuses
herself to go to the washroom and lee
takes the opportunity to go to chi he
drags her outside the restaurant and
asks her how she can be okay seeing him
with another woman she looks at him in
confusion when he confesses that he
likes her subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like if you think that lee was a beta
male thank you for watching